[Music]
that's it for today's episode of
Jeopardy unel by reminding you to get
your
transexual transmission trans
transist transgender athletes spade and
NCT before they compete in fenale
sports how's it going everybody I'm Dave
Ruben this is the Ruben report it's
December 5th 2023 we're live streaming
on Rumble locals and YouTube Share
subscribe tap that notification Bell and
if you want to join us as always for the
postgame show Ruben report. locals.com
and it is or is the season to be jolly
so we have launched some new merch over
at dve ruin. store I think we have some
images of new things images of new
things you can get hats and hoodies and
mugs and more and you can support the
show and all that good stuff and make
your family joyous during the holiday
season the theme of today's show is that
the far-left in the media have become
completely insane not mostly insane not
generally insane completely utterly and
totally insane and we are going to
expose it using clips from both
corporate media and some stuff online
we're going to show you the view we
haven't done anything with the view in a
little bit we've got Potato Man Brian
stelter he's back and we're going to try
to show you something that I think is
worth you noting which is that they
really really want Trump to be the
nominee they are pushing Trump because
they believe he is the guy that Joe
Biden can beat and they are doing
everything they can to make sure that
Ronda santis gets no traction because I
think it is fairly obvious he has more
of a crossover appeal what I would like
to do with that knowledge is figure out
how can we build a bridge between say
the Trump and DeSantis camps if not the
candidates themselves between those of
us who actually believe in Freedom who
think the United States is I don't know
pretty good and who would like to see
this experiment continue so that's what
we're going to be doing today let's dive
right into it Brian stelter shamed
Potato Man formerly of CNN who got fired
from CNN because he was pushing all the
lies on a program called reliable
sources which had they only called it
unreliable sources would have been much
more
better he then gets fired from CNN he
ends up teaching journalism at Harvard
which tells you everything you need to
know about our academic institutions uh
they brought him back on The View
yesterday to talk about the media and
people who lie in the media and he
talked to pet Republican Alyssa barah
Griffin out just that irony is dead go
can I mention one thing I do think
because I have a few friends at Fox they
have a handful of very good reporters
like Trey Yanks Jennifer Griffin people
who cover actual news and it is so hard
for that journalist those journalists
that they have to be next to basically
people espousing propaganda that's what
makes it a very uncomfortable
environment it's multiple things in one
fox though it still is the Beating Heart
of the GOP I think it's really important
to study it for that reason we have to
know how it works and how it sometimes
doesn't work how it goes wrong because
we should all Advocate to have a truth
year healthier environment that's why I
love this show you guys are louder than
the Liars got be louder than the Liars
Brian you're welcome at this table at
this very truthy
table that
rather what do we want to call him
doughy portly fella there um he wrote a
book called network of Lies while
working for CNN strike one he then goes
on The View says that he loves the view
because they're truthy strike to he then
sits with a woman and takes questions
from Alysa Farah who is a pretend
conservative on what is completely a
wackadoodle woke leftist show and they
pretend that there are some good guys at
Fox but it's mostly propaganda they need
only a mirror to figure out where the
propaganda is coming from and again this
is a man who was fired he was too
radical were CNN he was too his lies had
been debunked so many times on CNN from
Russia collusion Brett kavanau is a
serial rapist the Covington we've done
this a million times you guys get all of
it we thought we'd just show you a quick
compilation of Brian stelter's best
moments on CNN people love these things
because he's a portly fella who lies
about a lot of
stuff that would be funny if it wasn't
so Insidious jinning up hate CNN is so
much bigger than any single individual
too much of the US media chatter is
distorted to the point of being
dishonest don't be so hateful is that
too much to ask I don't know maybe it is
Trust in Media has CNN lost trust we're
living in two different realities
supported by two different news worlds
it's almost like we need two kinds of
newscasts uh or two versions of the
weather report the forecast is pretty
sunny for the vaccinated but it's quite
Bleak in some states for the
unvaccinated I'm glad that we work in a
building where everyone's vaccinated
looking at to 2020 one reason why I'm
taking you seriously as a contender is
because of your presence on cable
news what does the Press get wrong when
covering Biden's agenda when you watch
the news when you read the news what do
you think we get wrong I'm going to go a
little bit uh Rogue here so bear with me
okay Trump's odd behavior with Vladimir
Putin is compelling so many people to
ask what does Putin have on Trump has
Trump been compromised when you see um
entire media companies essentially exist
to tear down Joe Biden is there an
equivalent to that on the left tearing
down
Trump you're cracking me up the lying
the deception the anti-media attacks it
is getting worse being clear about the
threat to democracy is one of the most
important things that American
journalists can do reducing a liar's
reach is not the same as censoring
freedom of speech freedom of speech is
different than freedom of reach I feel
like he's filled with jelly like they
just like you know what I mean like
there's I'm not making fun of anyone way
I guess I am to some extent but there's
something about his type of roundness
like it's very jelly filled anyway uh he
continued on The View and uh this far
Griffin woman lady again whatever
they're paying you your soul could not
have been worth this little here she is
explaining that his book network of Lies
a man again who is fired from CNN for
lying and he's on The View where they
spread more Li to mainstream American
women who were confused about a whole
bunch of stuff than anywhere else that
his book network of Lies is a very
important book but you got this
important book out um and I I have to
ask you so uh in after Decades of
running the company rert Murdoch
announced that he was going to step down
he's passing the Baton to Lan Murdoch
there's a lot of intrigue around this
family and this you know is it going to
look different Under the Sun tell us
what we could expect and what you
learned in writing this right rer Muro
was so cozy with Donald Trump at the
start of the Trump presidency they were
best buds on the phone the relationship
fell apart he hates Trump now but
Rupert's handed off to his son laan and
this is really real life succession this
is you know crazy billionaire
Thanksgiving you know Lan Murdoch is
just as conservative as his dad but is
not as interested in politics doesn't
care as much about politics so I'm told
he doesn't really like Trump but he's
also not doing anything to try to step
in the way of this anti-democratic
movement so it's ultimately driven by
the ratings well the yes that's right
and the other brother James is on the
outside maybe someday he can take over I
mean that's sort of the Cliffhanger in
the book what's going to happen in the
event of rer Murdoch's death but that's
awkward to say out loud and right now
James is just on the outside right and
he's less conservative correct he
definitely has more of a vision of
dragging Fox back to real you really
need to understand how these people
operate in media world do you think that
Brian stelter or anyone that Brian
stelter knows has any access to the
Murdoch family has any real insight into
the meetings that the family is having
at their Thanksgiving parties or how one
might feel about Trump or anything else
he also did a little of The Accidental
pull the curtain back and see how
ridiculous the whole thing is when he
basically was like well the sun isn't
going to really do anything to stop
Trump well why would that be the job of
a news organization to stop a particular
candidate I thought they were supposed
to report on the
truth but I'm old school anyway I don't
really have a segue for this one but uh
here's Sunny host explaining that her
family doesn't like her there is a
scandal in the host household another
one another one y a scandal field we are
a scandal family because we ruled by
committee which we need to stop doing I
ordered an artificial gold tree this
year oo and it's fabulous how trumpish I
was just going to face and my daughter
that sounds very trumpish you have a
picture is it I do have a picture I
don't know if we can show it but I said
palom said we can't show it palom is
like yay and Gabriel was like that is
not good for the environment and I said
yes it is it's better for the
environment and he's like it's horrible
then my husband was like what is that
and so everybody's turned against me in
my house just because I'm trying to be
echo-friendly and then I just read Echo
and then you read about the tree that
you just bought want to put your dog G
Gabriel was right real trees help fight
climate change my kids nobody likes you
lady uh she's also trying to be
echo-friendly I think she means
eco-friendly L unless she's being
friendly in a echo echo that's an echo
echo echo echo ech eological
[Music]
like okay um so what other conservative
outside of Alysa Fara is carrying water
for the left in the media I'm going to
tell you on the other side but let's
talk about Oxford Club first guys I want
to share something truly exciting
picture this an investment opportunity
that's been quietly generating
substantial income outside of the chaos
of the stock market this isn't your
typical stock Bond or option it's
something bigger something that's been
delivering incredible returns we're
stepping into unprecedent an
unprecedented energy bull market akin to
the booming 70s where the demand for oil
is skyrocketing think about it China's
hunger for energy the US replenishing
reserves and the global conflicts
altering the oil landscape with Russia's
exports disrupted and OPEC scaling back
oil supply is plunged precisely when
demand is soaring predictions are in
brace your self for much higher oil
prices Global demand is set to hit a
staggering 101 million barrels per day
driving prices and royalties to new
heights but here's the game changer oil
and gas royalties picture collecting
income without the roller coaster ride
of drilling exploration costs or
workforce management just sit back and
reap the rewards from oil sales now the
golden opportunity we're talking about a
peran basin royalty stream the crown
jewel of oil reserves Warren Buffett's
wager to cool 12 billion on this region
and listen to this while stocks bonds
and crypto stumbled this royalty stream
soared with a staggering 149% returns in
2022 alone quarterly Revenue growth
boasting and EST sounding 77% and over
42 million in rev over the past year
consistency is key right well this
royalty stream has been serving up
monthly dividends and payments without
fail since
2,276 consecutive months of study income
so listeners imagine being part of this
success story don't let this opportunity
slip by and step into an investment
that's proven lucrative and ready to
fuel your financial future go to 2024
oil boo.com or click the link below and
get started today okay so I always give
Alysa Farah a little extra ribbing
because it's like okay stunny hustin
you're evil you're racist your family
doesn't like you we get it Joy bear you
have Trump derangement syndrome there's
too many injections in your face one got
too close to your brain you've lost your
mind whoopy you're smoking too much weed
eat drinking too much eggnog okay those
are all easy ones but Alyssa because she
is the pet conservative I always feel
that I have to kind of needle her a
little bit extra because it's for a
check that she is selling out all of her
beliefs the other ones it's like I
believe their brains are broken this
girl is just like I'm taking the cash
I'll say whatever you want and I'll
pretend to be a republican while
destroying anyone valuable and and and
sort of lifting up all of the pathetic
other pet Republicans like Mitt Romney
who she used to work for uh anyway
speaking of the those types of
Republicans who's making the rounds
she's back baby sure she lost her
congressional seat by like 60 points
nobody likes her and she should
disappear and not be heard from anywhere
but Liz Cheney that's right she's back
on the mainstream media because there's
nothing more that the mainstream media
loves than a pathetic loser Republican
who will take out other Republicans and
here's Liz Cheney again woman who lost
her congressional seat by something like
40 or 60 points uh talking about that
scary orange man we're facing a
situation with respect to the 2024
election uh where it's an existential
crisis uh and we have to ensure that we
don't have a situation where an election
that might be thrown into the House of
Representatives um is overseen by a
republican majority so you would prefer
a democratic
majority I believe very strongly in in
those principles and ideals that have
defined the Republican party but the
Republican party of today has made a
choice and they haven't chosen the
Constitution and so I do think it's uh
it presents a threat if the Republicans
are in the majority in January 20125
he's told us what he will do people who
say well if he's elected it's not that
dangerous because we have all of these
checks and balances don't fully
understand the extent to which the
Republican an in Congress today um have
been co-opted one of the things that we
see happening today is sort of a a
sleepwalking into a dictatorship in the
United States Donald Trump a fascist I
think that he certainly is employing
fascist techniques I think that the the
tools that he's using are tools that
we've seen used by authoritarians
fascists tyrants around the world it's
so interesting I'll unpack it bit but
notice she doesn't really say anything
and this is what they so consistently do
and when I was on real time on Friday
with uh James Carville he did the same
sort of thing they were talking about
the scary Republicans and they're mean
and they're going to usher in Fascism
and you've never seen people like them
and they're really scary and they're
coming for your freedoms and they want
to be dictators but they never lay it
out they never lay out how are they
going to do it what are they going to do
they're just scaring you with all the
stuff so first off uh what I'd like like
to know from Liz Cheney because she said
that they would gladly these new
Republicans led by fascist Donald Trump
would gladly destroy the Constitution
now she references checks and balances
we do have checks and balances so let's
say Donald Trump came in and said I am
taking over we are not going to have
three branches of the government anymore
I am president I am King well we do have
three branches of government and the
courts would stand against him and
Congress even if some of the people have
gotten a little wacky would stand
against him it's you can't just rip it
up just like that now you might say
actually that having the government of
the United States uh Prosecuting
selectively Prosecuting a former
president and a current presidential
candidate for various trumped up no pun
intended charges uh going against him
for things that other people have done
like Joe Biden and Mike Pence when it
comes to classified documents or going
after his businesses in New York like
all of the stuff that you all know about
you might say that's a little kind of
fascist right it's a little fascist like
because you know he was a businessman
and you're going after his businesses
that helps other competitive businesses
and it's the government doing it and
it's that collusion between government
and business that is the fascist thing
uh so they accuse of course Trump and
Republicans and basically you and me of
doing all the things that they are
willfully uh doing uh but she continued
because she's got to keep people scared
and she's making the rounds this is what
it's very it's a really good career so I
I tip my hat to you Liz Cheney for
keeping your career and your grift and
an Alysa Faris style way going uh she
not only made it on that show she also
made it to the televised mental
institution known as MSNBC with Rachel
mattow you know there was a moment right
after uh January 6th where I was having
dinner with my husband and our two
youngest kids um who happen to be our
sons and and I looked at my sons across
the dinner table and and I had this
realization you know I grew up in a
country where I didn't have to wonder if
we were going to have a peaceful
transfer of power in the United States
and all of a sudden it occurred to me my
God maybe they won't be able to say the
same thing and and that is why it's so
fundamentally important that we we
ensure Democrats Independents
Republicans that we we work together we
vote together we make clear that Donald
Trump is not an acceptable alternative
he is not the lesser of two evils he is
a complet unfit man for office he's
already shown us what he would do and he
can never be near the Oval Office again
sounds a vote for Donald Trump uh May
mean the last election that you ever get
to vote in and again I I don't say that
lightly um and it it I think is
heartbreaking that that's where we are
but people have to recognize that that
the vote for Donald Trump is a vote
against the Constitution well lady you
don't say it lightly but you do say it
totally dishonestly look I have been
very critical of trump I have a lot of
trump people constant L pissed at me
even when I defend him or I say that if
it doesn't work out for disantis I will
support him I think the way he has run
this campaign and being afraid of
debating and lying relentlessly about
DeSantis and Florida and the name
calling and and all of the behavior I
think has been absolutely abhorent and
it is not good for democracy and I don't
think even if he becomes president that
he will fix much much of this stuff I
just don't think he can staff properly
and all those things notice how I just
made specific criticisms of Behavior
Staffing issue that is a legitimate
issue the fact that he'd be a one-term
president that he's got Vengeance on his
mind there are things that you can
specifically say about him that are
problems but not these broad things that
if he comes in it will be the last time
you ever vote my God it will be the last
time you ever vote but there's this
weird thing with Trump which is that the
media which on one hand they want to
scare the F out of you related to Donald
Trump because he's Hitler and a Nazi and
a fascist that's a lot uh on the other
hand they really constantly are propping
him up again when I went on real time
every time I brought up something good
that the santis did they tried to turn
it back to Trump because the corporate
press wants Trump they know his
negatives are high they know the amount
of people that hate him they know all
the sides shows and the incompetence and
all that stuff and they also know that
Joe Biden has dementia and they are
dragging his old bones to the finish
line so you need a really beatable
candidate the ju toos of having say a
young
45-year-old mentally and physically fit
Ronda santis with a track record and a
vision on stage with Joe Biden is a huge
problem for them it's much less of a
problem to have Donald Trump on stage
with Joe Biden which by the way I am n
I'm gonna make I don't know that anyone
has said this publicly I'm going to take
a prediction right now uh Joe Biden will
not debate period there will be no
debates Trump has set a horrible predent
as it comes to debates you don't have to
debate I have my reasons I'm up by 50
points in these polls I have my reasons
well Joe Biden they don't want him to
debate obviously they really don't want
him to debate the santis because it'll
be just so Stark the difference between
the two but they don't want him to
debate Trump either and the the the hit
that he would take by not debating
people would be like oh Biden should
debate uh would be much less than
putting him on stage and having a mental
breakdown so Trump has said a horrible
precedent that Biden will use against
Trump and the Republicans and everything
else but anyway it's becoming just
increasingly obvious they just want
Trump they want Trump cuz they know he's
beatable and now I'd like to show you
some video from ABC News ABC News you're
not going to believe this guys it's open
it's owned by the Disney Corporation and
uh Disney is no fan of Ronda santis
because he took away all of their
special rights that they had here in the
State of Florida he even the playing
field this is something that Nikki Haley
and uh several other people including
Mike Pence were very critical of Ronda
santis for removing corporate cronyism
but of course he did the right thing and
I think most people do see that uh but
here's ABC News uh good morning America
and they're very excited that do santis
is apparently struggling in these polls
and you know they very clearly seem to
want this orange fella race for the
White House now the Republican
candidates are descending on Iowa ahead
of the first contest of the campaign
season next month Rachel Scott has the
latest on that good morning Rachel
George good morning to you we are just
six weeks out from the Iowa caucuses
Florida Governor Ronda santis going all
in on that state visiting all 99
counties but he's losing ground to Nikki
Haley and he's still far behind Donald
Trump this morning all eyes on the
Hawkeye State with just over a month
until the Iowa caucuses we did the 99
now we need pus night the victory God
bless Governor Ronda Sans is reaching a
milestone over the weekend visiting all
99 counties in the state we are going to
win the Iowa caucus and that is going to
propel us to being the 47th president of
the United States but problems are
mounting for the Florida governor
tensions running high within his Super
PAC now moving on to its third CEO in
just two weeks weeks and Des santis is
on the attack as he loses ground to
former South Carolina Governor Nikki
Haley what I would just say is she
clearly um is not a conservative I think
if you look at her record as South
Carolina governor people can't even
identify any major achievements that she
had still Donald Trump is the clear
front runner mocking his Rivals at a
rally this weekend we hit him very hard
and he's uh he's been falling out of the
air like a very seriously wounded bird
right to you see what they did there who
do you think they really fear they're
going after Dan santis they by the way
they keep telling you that he's losing
ground to Nikki Haley I don't know
anyone that's supporting Nikki Haley I
know that there's you know the coch
network I guess is supporting her and
there's some corporate stuff behind her
I I like her personally she has been to
my house for dinner she is a lovely
lovely lovely human being but the
corporate press kind of likes her more
than they like Ronda santis and
shouldn't ABC every time they talk about
Ronda santis say and by the way Ronda
santis demolished Disney who owns this
network wouldn't that be an honest way
of assessing it but then they tell you
he's losing ground to Nikki Haley again
there's just no evidence of that how
many of you know anyone that's
supporting Nikki Haley is Nikki Haley
drawing big crowds anywhere oh my God
the Haley movement like it just doesn't
exist right it just doesn't we all know
that the Chris Christie movement it's
huge Chris Christie even seems less
jelly filled to me than stelter somehow
like he seems it seems more natural
where there's the jelly thing with
stelter anyway
um but then of course they say and he's
losing to Donald Trump and then they
play the Trump clip like Trump's the
good guy now see he's spinning and
spinning spinning out of control because
they want Donald Trump here's how ABC
covered the Ronda sanis Gavin Nome
debate and you tell me if this seems in
any way congruent with what you saw out
of that debate not last night's debate
between Florida Governor Ronda santis
and California governor Gavin Nome a red
state Blue State Showdown Chief
Washington correspondent John Carl here
with the highlights good morning John
right at the start of the debate
California governor Gavin Nome who isn't
running for president taunted Florida
Governor Ronda santis who is running but
trailing badly with a reminder that
neither of them would likely be on the
ballot next fall there's one thing in
closing that we have in common is
neither of us will be the nominee for
our party in
2024 the debate was however something of
a foreshadowing of the Cas Republicans
will bring against President Biden
people used to be able to work hard and
get ahead that is not true under Joe
Biden and the kind of Defense Democrats
can offer of what Nome called Biden
nomics 3.9% unemployment the lowest
black unemployment in American history
the lowest unemployment for Hispanics in
American history the lowest unemployment
for women in 70 years the lowest black
poverty rates in history for disantis it
was a chance to try to inject some
energy into a campaign that badly needs
it as Nome gleefully pointed out you're
trolling folks and trying to find
migrants to play political games try to
get some news and attention so you can
out Trump trump and by the way how's
that going for you Ron you're down 41
points in your own home state less than
a year ago Dan santis was leading Donald
Trump in polls of Republican voters but
he has been losing ground for months now
trailing Nikki haly okay so first off
there is no evidence that he is trailing
Nikki Haley they seem to want Haley see
that what's happening here again this is
a a company an organiz a news
organization that's owned by Disney so
do you think they have a little problem
with Ronda santis secondly the clips
that they just showed you there every
single one was to make Gavin nuum look
as good as possible right and every
single one was to make Ronda santis look
as bad as possible and you would think
if the same network thinks that Donald
Trump is a fascist hitler-like nazi
dictator that they might be uh helping
the guy that could take him out but the
truth is the santis is the one guy that
they are actually afraid of like you
just have to understand basic psychology
here so now I want to show you something
I was so absolutely elated to see this
yesterday uh Jordan Peterson finally sat
down with Ronda santis they did it over
over video it wasn't in person
unfortunately uh but it is an absolutely
wonderful 1 hour video and Jordan set
out I highly recommend you guys watch
the full thing we're going to show you
two clips right now but Jordan set out
to do something that I thought was
really nice he said at the top you know
everyone gets it on policy you you you
have great policy you have you are
competent you don't lie the way
politicians do he laid it out really
nicely he said what I would like to know
is a little bit more about what makes
you tick I want to know a little bit
more about your history personality sort
of how you go about making decisions and
it was really really great and I want to
to show you two clips uh well take a
look at the first one if you're going to
be on the political landscape you have
to be extroverted generally speaking and
one of the things that extroversion
especially in combination with less
agreeableness tilts people towards is a
kind of narcissism and so there's a lot
of people in the political domain media
entertainment as I said who are in the
public eye who tilt towards narcissism
but the great leaders that I've seen are
people who are very good at
listening who are very good at building
teams and who might balance their
ambition with conscientious ious now it
seems to me very clear that you're a
conscientious person because you stress
hard work continually and you also say
that you enjoy it and those are
Hallmarks of someone who's conscientious
and that's a very good trait personality
predictor of long-term success it's the
best predictor after general
intelligence what I'm I'm curious about
the mechanics of how you go about
building a team how you've done that in
Florida and what you think you might
bring to bear if you were in Washington
I I read a fair bit about Donald Trump's
early year in first year in in office
and it was definitely the case that it
was hard for him to build a functional
team okay so that was obviously Jordan
sort of setting up what the whole
premise of the interview is going to be
now let's get into a a little more of
them actually talking about how you
build an effective team I don't need the
credit and in fact when things don't go
as well one of the things a leader has
to do is say okay I'm responsible for
that so there are there times and and
and and I I I think you you can't be a
really good leader if you try to
micromanage anything I mean you've got
to set the vision set expectations and
you've got to give people the
opportunity to do it without you picking
at them and and that's the only way I
think you can really do well the flip
side to that though is that sometimes
when you delegate like that the the job
doesn't get done and people may do
things that that are not in line with
the vision and so what you just have to
be able to do is you just have to take
the necessary action to correct that
sometimes you got to replace Personnel
sometimes just uh internal course
correction but I think it's important
that you you praise the people that are
working for you in public and you censor
in private I don't believe in in
throwing people under the bus I think
they got to know that you're going to
have their back what's that thing I
always tell you when you hear the truth
like it's just kind of easy to hear and
you can sit in your chair and you don't
have to you don't feel that tension
because lies actually like they they
Fray the very nature of reality and you
know when someone's lying and here he is
calmly laying out how he believes you
should build a team and where you should
give give credit and how you shouldn't
throw people under the bus and all that
and you could really see and again I I
hope you guys will watch the full hour
and I hope that they do it again before
Iowa um because they were just beginning
to scratch the surface and Des santis
talks about his childhood and his family
like it's really a different interview
than you've ever seen um but you get
that good insight into what he what
makes him tick and when you have someone
who actually is decent and is out there
trying to do the right thing what you
get are good policies and that's exactly
what we have here in Florida so now I
want to just jump back and I think
you've probably seen them I want to show
you two clips from that debate with
Newsome because Newsome stood up there
and lied about absolutely everything
including black and Latino unemployment
at the all-time low he lied about
absolutely every everything every time
Hannity showed a stat people leaving
Cali and uh going to Florida and talking
about taxes every time Nome disputed it
or just pretended it didn't exist uh
here's the S it's just laying out some
truth about why people have moved to
Florida and what's going on in
California how does paying $7 a gallon
gas help working people that doesn't
help working people at all how does
paying an 8% sales tax help working
people that doesn't help working people
at all uh they have the highest taxes in
the nation people flee to be able to
save money uh to get out of California
and you have workingclass people that
move to these other states their dollars
go much further but here's the thing
they want to take this biomics and they
want to double down on this for the next
four years how many people are able to
afford groceries now compared to what
you were doing three or four years ago I
talked to people you know I talked to a
woman who had a had a a card full of
groceries going in and they're ringing
it up and it got to be so expensive she
has to take a lot of the stuff out that
didn't used to be the case people used
to be able to work hard and get ahead
that is not true under Joe Biden and you
know what Sean one more final
thing California's unemployment rate is
60% higher than Florida's unemployment
rate our unemployment rate is
2.8% look at the way Newsome Just Smiles
through that they have 60% more
unemployment in California than Florida
Florida is freaking flourishing and I
know you know it and I know it can
probably be repetitive when I say it but
this is the choice we have to make do we
want competency and real ity and good
governance or do we want more lunacy now
I get it that the Democrats are offering
us just sheer just drive right off the
cliff lunacy I think the Trump thing's a
different version of that that would be
at least delay it a little or be
slightly different uh but you can see
that the STIs is clearly laying out what
the better option would be uh let's just
do one more with disantis and Newsome
well I'll tell you what it's deja vu all
over again with that flurry of Lies this
is a guy that says the bid
Administration is not lying to the
public about the Border they go to the
white house uh briefing room every day
they say the border secure they are
lying to you we know that that's not
true Gavin Newsome is lying to you when
he says somehow I supported these things
which I didn't do he's also lying to you
uh about what it's going to take to
solve this problem California is a
sanctuary State uh they thumb their nose
at Federal immigration law and this has
real consequences uh there was an
illegal alien Herbert Nixon Flores uh
who was in LA uh in custody he was a
repeat criminal ice wanted to take him
into custody because then they would be
able to deport him La refuses to work
with ice and so they wouldn't turn him
over they end up releasing him on the
street he ends up murdering the mother
of a three-year-old little girl uh that
those policies are deadly uh they do not
work the Martha's Vineyard transport
Martha's Vineyard said it was a
sanctuary jurisdiction kind of reminds
me about Gavin Nome when he restricted
Californians then he went to the French
Laundry these liberal Elites they like
to impose burdens on you they don't want
to have to face the consequences of
their actions so we've got a lot of
Elites who want open borders who lecture
everybody else about it then the minute
they have to deal with any of the
consequences oh man all hell breaks
loose they get okay so I don't have to
offer much uh analyzing there because
every single thing he said there is true
and particularly as it pertains to the
border and you know it we're going to
cover some more videos tomorrow there is
some craziness happening on the border
in Arizona right now with people just
absolutely pouring through at the same
point as the sanis correctly points out
as the as the administration will tell
us that the border is secure and
everything else but the reason I wanted
to show you that clip was really to get
us to the next segment which is about
the lying because they lie about
everything as Dan santis just said right
there as it pertains to immigration but
they have lied about virtually
everything for so long that it is hard
to figure out when they're lying anymore
but one of the things that they're
constantly lying about is that Donald
Trump is racist right and by extension
the Republicans are racist and by the
way even though Dan santis G doesn't get
pinned as racist that often if he is the
eventual nominee they will push that on
him too yes they do say he's racist he
didn't want that black African-American
studies course where they were going to
teach queer theory in Florida so that
made him racist but like they haven't
like fully done that one with DeSantis
just yet but everything the Democrats
the mainstream media do is based on a
lie so what would be the best example of
this let's talk about Charlottesville
for a moment because you know a couple
times in the last week or two I've
mentioned how that Joe Biden launched
his campaign his campaign launch video
was a lie it was about the
Charlottesville incident and very fine
people on both sides we have not shown
you that video in about two years here's
just a segment of it now just one more
time this is when Joe Biden announced
his campaign this is the video they put
out to say I'm running for president it
was based on a lie enjoy charlotesville
Virginia is home to the author of one of
the great documents in human history we
know it by heart we hold these truths to
be self-evident that all men are created
equal endowed by their creator with
certain in alienable rights we've heard
it so often it's almost a cliche but
it's who we are we haven't always lived
up to these ideals Jefferson himself
didn't but we have never before walked
away from them Charlottesville is also
home to a defining moment for this
nation in the last few
[Music]
years will
not it was there on August of 2017 we
saw clansmen and white supremacists and
neo-nazis come out in the
open they crazed faces illuminated by
torches veins bulging and bearing the
fangs of racism he said there were quote
some very fine people on both sides very
fine people on both sides Joe Biden
later in that video goes on to explain
that that was the moment that he decided
to run for president right he didn't
vote run for president when Barack Obama
who he was obviously his vice president
when Obama finished up his two terms
right Hillary Ran So it seemed like
Biden was out but then he frames it as
if that moment with those bulging vains
and the neo-nazis and the white
supremacists and then Donald Trump
saying very fine people on both sides I
had to run for president well you're not
going to believe this using the latest
in technology we have the actual video
of what Donald Trump said that day it's
fine you're changing history you're
changing culture and you had people and
I'm not talking about the neo-nazis and
the white nationalists because they
should be condemned totally but you had
many people in that group other than
neo-nazis and white nationalists so he
condemns the neo-nazis and the white
nationalists that's what he did on that
very day and the and Joe Biden ran a
campaign and think about the gall of
these people they knew that that Trump
video was out there but the mainstream
media has so much power over everybody
and this is why they hate Elon Musk
because he's freeing our ability to be
able to get video out there to counter
this and this is why I do this show on
Rumble so that we can counter this
nonsense but they had the G knowing that
they have so much cultural power over us
and they own all of the media
institutions and everything else that
they can literally have a man with
dementia announced that he's running for
president because of something that is a
lie that is the most simply easily
debunked thing and virtually nobody has
done it nobody has done it and that lie
has run rampant for years Donald Trump
was talking about very fine people on
both sides of the debate as it pertains
to what you do with these old statues
meaning some people might say a Robert
statue is a historical document let's
say and some people might say well he
was a bad dude and he was for the
Confederacy we should debate what we
should do with those statues that is a
legitimate debate and there are very
fine people on both sides of that debate
should we put it in a Robert elely
statues should they be moved and put in
a museum perhaps should there be a
counter Monument right next to them a
plaque something like that you can
honestly have a debate about that and
not necessarily be a Neo-Nazi or a or a
white supremacist but Trump goes out of
his way to do it you guys get it any
anyway I'm bringing all this up because
I think the the important thing for me
to be able to do at this moment is
defend Trump when it is necessary which
I have no problem doing even though I
have just spent 20 minutes on today's
show clearly laying out that I think
Ronda santis is a better candidate now
unfortunately what we've seen is that
the pundit class is just going in their
their directions everyone's just going
to where wherever Their audience is and
and basically like spoon feeding you
guys garbage and I refuse to do that to
you I I think you guys deserve better
and if that's what you want then there's
another show that you should be watching
so I will call balls and Strikes as I
see them and one other guy who I can who
I'm so proud to call a friend and and a
colleague through what we do at Rumble
uh is Dan banino Dan Bonino is on the
Trump side of this thing I am on the
disantis side of this thing but Dan is
calling balls and Strikes the way I am
and he saw me on uh on Real Time call
out this nonsense with James Carville
and he gave me a little credit and I
think it's worth so I'm playing this not
to Pat myself on the back I'm pay I'm
playing this to give banino a little
credit cuz we are on opposite sides of
this thing but we're both fighting for
truth and for America and I think that's
important to note Carville was on bill
marah this weekend with a friend of mine
Dave Rubin who did a good job by the way
and I credit him he's a disantis guy but
he's my friend and a good friend and he
did the right thing he could have
knocked Trump on this Charlottesville
thing and Dave didn't and this is the
kind of stuff I credit people with even
when we don't support the same guy he's
a good man okay he can you know he can
fight for his guy here's car Ville this
is a sign here they are ready to go full
Charlottesville on Trump even though
that good people thing is a total
hoax check this out the kids seem to be
with the
Palestinians and the older generation
seems to be with Israel well the kids
are with Tik Tock they're with whatever
Tik Tock tell them to be for basically
well that is where a lot of what would a
good people on both sides of Charles
will I don't know did I hear that or did
I make that up that Trump said they're
good people on both sides he he didn't
say that he did not he well he said it
but a sentence later he said I'm not
talking about the white supremacists and
and the Neo naazi yeah I
have it's
like what what what is he laughing about
Carville what is he laughing about Trump
literally said I'm not talking about
those people he that's what he actually
said folks Carville say this is not an
accident okay although that may not have
been an intended part of his little
monologue there whatever the hell he was
doing on Bill Mars show it's now clear
to me that now that the Biden
record is totally not savable and that
Magics is starting to Trend no I'm not
kidding I didn't make that up don't
credit me with it Magics people are
starting to go back go wait where's my
wallet wait it was a lot thicker in the
Trump years holy I'm losing money
with Biden now that Magics is starting
to Trend that people are starting to go
all right whatever you don't like his
personality you don't like this he's too
much of a Queens guy a New York guy
Trump yeah I don't really care I want my
business to succeed the Biden team's
freaking out so how do you get people to
hate him you gotta go full
Charlottesville You Gotta Go full
Charlottesville and again even though as
Dan just said we happen to be on
different sides in in this primary the
side that Dan and I are are is the side
of truth it's the side of America so I
have no problem uniting with Dan banino
against the forces that will lie
relentlessly against James Carville who
at this point like either James Carville
is a he's a complete liar like he's just
like a Democrat hack or he's an idiot
who shouldn't be on television now I I
say that meaning I spent some time in
the green room with the guy right
beforehand he wasn't mean we had a nice
little chat for a moment and as I said
to you yesterday the next time I go on
the show I'm not going to sit in the
green room with the other guest cuz once
you become friendly for a moment with
somebody it's hard 10 minutes before to
be kind of laughing with somebody or how
your kids or tell me about your life and
then they say something idiotic on the
show and you kind of want to pull the
punches so you could see the way I
softly I didn't jump on him I said well
actually here's what happened but either
Carville has he's either a complete liar
which he's a he's a Democrat campaign uh
spokesman so you know in essence he is a
or he's an idiot but either way I don't
see how you could put someone like that
on television anymore anyway Dan you
watching this if you don't see eye to
eye to me anyone else that believes in
truth and freedom in America and wants
to get out of this nonsense and not call
all of the people who are actually
generally Standing Up Against Racism
racist and everything else we got to
figure out a way out of this and I think
one of the interesting things that's
that's happening right now is that we
are getting this crosssection of people
who are calling out the BS more and more
and they're doing it in a way often
using provocative language because they
have been pushed into a corner and there
is nothing else to say other than this
little compilation we're about to show
you from Dana White Tucker Carlson and
Elon Musk and one of our big sponsors
called and said take that down you know
what I said oh yourself
yeah F you yeah don't ever call me and
tell me who to vote for and if your
recourse is you're a bad person for not
believing me you that's my
you black m with money go yourself go
yourself is that
clear I hope it
is Dana White Tucker Carlson and Elon
mus don't have a ton in common
politically or culturally or probably
where they're from or any of that stuff
but why are these people being pushed
into a corner you know I was I was
watching that just now I was thinking
look over the last couple months it's
kind of become a running joke on this
show how often I've either said the f
bomb or tried not to say it or sometimes
I'm left with nothing else or like and
it's like that's what they're trying to
do with us they're trying to by through
censorship through lying
through all of the tricks that they have
they are pushing the rest of us into a
very bizarre place where we don't have
much other than F you enough is enough
and maybe that attitude is what we need
to really get to the other side of this
thing I think it probably is I want to
show you one more because uh my friend
rosean bar was on uh Bill Mah's podcast
uh talking about another way it's not
just through censorship it's not just
through big Tech it's also that they
will come for your jokes if you just
tell a joke that they happen to not like
they will try to take you out and
remember what was it five years ago now
when they did the reboot of rosean bar
sitcom it when they it was called the
original one was Roseanne and then I
think the the reboot was called the
Connors it was the number one sitcom In
America when they brought it back number
one sitcom comedy in America she made
one off-hand joke no one in their right
mind thinks that she's a racist she made
one off-hand joke and they cancelled her
well here she is uh telling Bill what
she thinks about people who do that sort
of thing you if you can't take a joke
you you fascist that's how I feel
bill and you know what I don't give a
what color your ass is if you ain't
doing right for your own people or
anybody's people in this country where
people are sleeping in the streets and
it makes meing sick then you I
don't give a about your feelings you are
offensive to me you better take care of
people living and dying in these
streets
off a lot of beeping bleeping you know
what's funny about the bleeps look at my
finger that's from the bleeping you see
that I have a broken finger from all the
F bombs just kidding it's not from the F
bombs I was playing basketball last
night scored 15 points by the way hit
five threes my team did lose in the
playoffs but I broke my finger right at
the I think it's broken it looks like
it's broken something ain't right it's
not really yeah that it actually does it
look worse on television than it looks
in anyway I'll be all right don't worry
I'm a lefty anyway it's okay laugh last
Lefty thing about me is that I write it
with my left hand but anyway what brings
Roseanne Bar
and Bill Maher and Dana White and Elon
Musk and Tucker Carlson and me and you
together maybe it's truth maybe that The
Human Experience is so deeply connected
to truth that when they assault us and
assault us and assault us all we've got
left is f you so whether you like
DeSantis or you like Trump at least
let's really figure out what and who the
enemy is let's figure that out then we
can deal with the political stuff so
that's like the space that banino and I
are working between right now like we
happen to have different candidates at
the moment but we are united on we are
united
via something that is much bigger than I
like this guy you like this guy we have
to save this country this is the last
chance so let's go ahead and do it if
you'd like to join us for a postgame
show please do at Ruben report.
locals.com people of the internet with
the viral videos of the day and your
calls we'll be live at 1 p.m. Eastern
we've got a new account on x/ Twitter
for show clips it's Ruben report show we
leave you with an LOL cold close
goodbye okay recent polls have shown a
fifth of Americans can't locate the US
on a world map why do you think this is
I personally believe that us Americans
are unable to do so because uh some
people out there in our nation don't
have thats and I believe that our
education like such as in South Africa
and the Iraq everywhere like such as and
I believe that they should our education
over here in the US should help the us
or should help South Africa and should
help the Iraq and the Asian countries so
we will be able to build up our future
for our thank you very much South
Carolina
[Music]
by love that clip from what is that Miss
America or Miss Universe or something it
wasn't